[Music]
machine gun kelly popped the question to
megan fox last week and now a source
tells et that her ex brian austin green
couldn't care less about the engagement
news it is what it is quote he doesn't
have any lingering romantic feelings for
megan or any anger brian is happy for
her but it really isn't affecting him
one way or the other there's no bad
blood or ill-will between them at this
point i just was kind of in love with
him right away the two were married from
2010 to 2021 and share three sons
together nine-year-old noah
seven-year-old bodhi and five-year-old
journey
i've had a kid every other year since
2012
and that's just a it's a lot
and our source says the former beverly
hills 90210 star is just glad they are
co-parenting well together
brian's of course found new love of his
own he's been dating dancing with the
stars pro sharna burgess for more than a
year
it's just beyond what you would imagine
would happen
it's like two people that you just never
expect would
would cross paths it's really
it's cool
it's been nearly two years of dating for
megan and mgk
the pair met while filming midnight in
the switchgrass back in march 2020. he
shot only for two days on this movie
and that's how i met him
and then all the rest of that developed
afterwards so i mean working with him is
amazing honestly i don't know if people
understand what a good actor he is he's
so charismatic and he's so naturally
gifted and he's so intense he's also
a brilliant creative genius as a
musician so then for him to show up on
set and just be so much better than you
at what you do for a living is really
annoying he's really gifted he's an
amazing actor he's gonna win awards one
day
she later starred in his music video for
bloody valentine
[Music]
[Applause]
he's not allowed to have other hoes in
his music video
it's the queen or no one
and e.t source says megan really centers
the 31 year old musician quote mgk's
life can be chaotic and all over the
place but megan brings out his calmer
side she is a really humbling force for
mgk especially when he's on the road or
making music he's the most talented boy
in the world as for mgk our source says
he feels like she is the thing that he
can go home to at the end of the day and
feel at peace with
quote they're both very happy together
and can't wait to start their lives
together and get married
as for that engagement bling well
it's one of a kind it was a perfect fit
the singer designed the piece himself
explaining on instagram that it features
an emerald megan's birthstone and a
diamond his birthstone and it's set on
two magnetic bands that draw together as
quote two halves of the same soul
forming the obscure heart that is our
love
whatever daddy says
oh but that's not all in an interview
with vogue mgk revealed the band is
actually made of thorns wow
quote if she tries to take it off it
hurts
love is pain
[Music]
you